time for some PFT props these are not
actual bets that you can place but these
are some things that we have identified
for the purposes of conversation and I
guess if some sports book out there
wants to use them they can let's start
with this one which number will be
higher in 2019 Tom Brady interceptions
or Stephen Gostkowski missed field goals
Gostkowski just residing with the
Patriots earlier this week yeah I mean
this is a good one I mean Gus Kowski of
course is one of the greatest kickers of
all time if memory serves me correct I
think his field goal percentage is what
third and the history of the sport right
now so I don't expect him to miss more
than six or seven in a year and that's
like a cold year for a guy like Stephen
Gostkowski so I'm gonna go with Brady
here I do think Brady is in the type of
part of his career where of course
things are going down and the one thing
I'll say too and defending Brady with
that is there are a more aggressive
passing team now than they were in 2011
and 12 and 13 where they were a little
bit dink and dunk at that time now
they're as more showing highlights
it's Brady throwing you know Hallett
sirs down in the middle of the field
more often and that of course can lead
to more interceptions yeah III don't
disagree with that although guess Kowski
even though his his overall percentage
is high just sticks in my head there's
been so many big kicks where you just
kind of scratch her head and say how's
the extra point from the AFC
championship game I know it's been three
years ago now but arguably kept the
Patriots out of yet another Super Bowl
alright more receiving touchdowns in
2019
ohto Beckham junior or sterling Shepherd
and Golden Tate combined for the New
York Giants yeah you know I'm gonna go
with Odell Beckham jr. here I think when
it comes down to touchdowns alone I
think this is where Odell Beckham jr.
will have a unbelievable football season
I don't think he's gonna lead the league
in receiving yards or anything like that
I think he's top five in that category
but I just think there's too much wealth
on that football team as far as talent
with Landry and joko Antonio Callaway
that'll take away some of his you know
catches and maybe yards to a degree but
I still think
he's gonna be a focal point for all the
big plays whether that's a post from the
50-yard line or its we're gonna design
red zone plays for Odell Beckham jr. cuz
he's one of the greatest 5050 jump ball
players we've ever seen in the league
that's where I think he will really make
a name for himself and I think Odell
Beckham jr. I'm gonna say now will lead
the league in receiving touchdowns this
year by the way oh no Beckham jr. took
to Twitter last night and suggested that
he's seen his team's schedule which I
just don't believe because if he sees it
that means someone else sees it and
eventually it gets reported the fact
that it isn't reported doesn't mesh with
the idea that obj is aware of the
schedule but apparently Chris he thinks
week one it's gonna be the Browns at the
Jets which would make that a very
compelling and I've seen some separate
speculation that that would be maybe the
early Monday Night Football game to cap
week one that would be pretty cool
coming back to New York and then we get
a little bit of first you know Friday
kitchens versus Adam GaSe and their
first you know times as a head coach
here in 29 Ray Williams Greg Brady
kitchens you know Baker Mayfield verse
and Arnold that was the start of that
last year when Baker Mayfield came in
and saved the day in the Thursday night
so I'd be all in for that matchup week
one that would be awesome
alright next prop which Bose has more
sex in 2019 Nick or Joey nick is a
Knicks especial player you know that
he's going in the top three picks of the
NFL Draft I think he will go to the San
Francisco 49ers at number two I'm gonna
still give Joey the edge here though
just because Joey I've seen him do it I
think if he stays healthy this is the
interesting thing about the player Mike
Joey to me is a more physical big strong
guy Nick Bosa is maybe more made to be a
pass rusher if that makes sense to you
his ability to kind of turn the corner
and just go get the quarterback he's
better than his brother at that but his
brothers a little bit more of a big guy
who can win with power and do a few
different things because of his size and
that but I'm still gonna go with Joey it
is Nick's rookie year and Joey's been
pretty phenomenal to this point in his
career why and and Joey's got Melvin
Avram on the other side and we don't
know what Nick BOCES can
and we don't know that he's definitely
gonna be taken by the 49ers at number
two it's just I think it's too premature
yeah to have enough faith in Nick that
yeah we've seen Joey do it and he's
proven and I'm always gonna take the
proven guy over the unproven guy who
signs a new deal first now that DeMarcus
Lawrence is under contract with the
Dallas Cowboys Stephen Jones the Cowboys
CEO has made it clear that the next guys
up are Amari Cooper and quarterback dak
Prescott which of those two do you think
signs oh well this is a no-brainer
it better be dak Prescott I mean that to
me they're flirting with danger if they
saw tree sign Amari Cooper who hasn't
been there for a full calendar year yet
over a guy who was their draft pick who
has led them to the play of the playoffs
two out of three years and of course got
his first playoff win this year and
played good even in the loss to the Rams
made a lot of big-time plays and really
kept them in because they couldn't run
the ball that day if everybody remembers
so I think it's got to be dak Prescott
just because of the history and Amari
Cooper again it was awesome at the end
of the year but I would just want to
make him prove to me at least for a few
weeks of this 2019 season that he's
gonna be the guy that we saw from last
year in Dallas and not the guy we saw
two and three years ago with the Oakland
Raiders yeah here's the thing though and
I can tell that you don't read Pro
Football Talk comm in your spare time I
do all the time I might have missed this
article what go ahead you you did miss
it I wrote this yesterday this structure
that they used for DeMarcus Lawrence is
easily transferable to Amari Cooper
because Cooper's due to make thirteen
point nine million this year under his
fifth year option next year at a minimum
sixteen point seven under the franchise
tag you can very easily throw together a
deal structure just like the Marcus
Lawrence and get it done you could
negotiate this deal in five minutes for
Cooper it's more complicated for dak
Prescott because he's only making two
million this year next year he'd make 25
yeah you could slap it together and say
we'll give you 27 million over the next
two years and that's not nearly gonna be
good enough for Doc press-conferences
that averages out to 13.5 million a year
right that's a more complicated
negotiation because he's making so
little this year
Cooper's is very easy Cooper's is
basically a recipe
for sugar cookies dak Prescott is a
full-course meal where you don't even
know what the ingredients are gonna be
yet and that is the the difference and
that's why I think Cooper gets a deal
first and I think Prescott will
understand it because Cooper's is gonna
be easier to do and they knock it out to
get it out of the way and then they
focus on dak Prescott meanwhile you got
to worry about a Zico Elliot's saying
hey how about me when do I get my
contract and we've even raised that
point in the past he may just need to
hold out to get the team's attention all
right one more before we break Aaron
Rodgers averaged 30 touchdown passes a
year under coach Mike McCarthy over
under this year with Matt Lafleur as the
head coach 30 touchdown passes for
Packers quarterback Aaron Rodgers yeah
I'm gonna go just over ok just over I
don't think this will be a like a 40
touchdown year for Aaron Rodgers or 38
or 45 I don't think that's happening 1 I
don't know if the weaponry for the Green
Bay Packers is good enough to put up
those type of numbers - I think the big
thing is with Matt Lafleur as head coach
and Nate Hackett as offensive
coordinator those are two offensive
minds that believe in running the
football
I mean Nate Hackett he was very good
with running the football the year the
Jacksonville Jaguars went to the AFC
championship game and he tried to stay
consistent with it last year as well
except the Jaguars were beat up up front
and that running back Matt Lafleur comes
from the Kyle Shanahan Sean McVeigh
school and they're all about running -
so I do think that maybe Hertz Rodgers
passing numbers but I still think he
gets over 30 yeah and look I just think
that the aftermath of this whole Tyler
done thing he is gonna be focused and
motivated and driven he's gonna want to
prove people wrong he's gonna show he
still has he's gonna like carry the team
as far as he can and he's gonna try to
do a lot now we can't rule out injuries
because that impaired him last year yeah
but I agree with you I think he's gonna
be over 30 all right we're over not
quite but it fit well with what I just
said we're gonna take a break when we
return we're gonna answer some of your
questions as we work our way through
this Thursday edition of pro football
talk live we'll be right back
you
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports